let's go next to our caller let's try
the 708 area code who's calling today
from 708
oh let's see 708 was dropped you're on
ok yeah go ahead 708
hi I'm Daniel from the Chicagoland area
hey Danny um so I've noticed you know
I'm I'm like a young guy and I'm like
very into politics and I've been
following your show and a couple other
shows for the past year or so and I've
noticed that like I'm very into policy
but like when I talk to my friends you
know there's a big gap in being informed
I think and like also misinformation
sure and I'm starting to think like that
you know as much as we try to find
solutions and try to convince others of
like progressive solutions and things
like that like when I look at say a
second choice poll like
Biden like most of Biden's second choice
there's his support or second choice is
Bernie Sanders and that like just
doesn't make sense to me which means
that like there must be some you know
like the large majority of the public is
not really informed on a lot of these
issues absolutely listen my
interpretation of that would be that
this is heavily driven that that reality
that'll that for Biden supporters their
number one alternative is Bernie is
basically a popularity and name
recognition thing combined with
personality it's like Biden's really
well known it was the former vice
president lots of people who liked the
Obama administration or at least liked
it in relation to the Trump
administration maybe leaning towards
Biden early as a result of that beyond
that bernie is sort of like the most
well known and he's relatively he has
high favorability of the other
candidates Elizabeth Warren is also
relatively well known so it makes
perfect sense and you're completely
right how could somebody who is
supporting Biden on policy say my next
choice is Bernie but but I think that
when you understand how politics works
in the United States it actually does
make sense do you think that like there
is a chance to kind of I know this is
largely what like a lot of the
progressive
is about is about doing politics based
on policy
yeah necessarily name recognition our
identity um do you think there's a
chance in this election that this can be
I know that's like Bernie's main message
like you go back to one he was debating
Hillary and he's like I don't want to
talk about your emails I want to talk
about policy yeah do you think there's a
chance in this election that that could
actually you know that could be the
favored way to evaluate the candidate
well listen Elizabeth Warren has been
making gains for about the last four
months about a point to a point and a
half a month on policy I mean she her
town halls are very policy centric she's
putting out a ton of policy papers on
her website and that has worked in a
sort of slow and steady way for her the
problem is that when you look at the
first democratic debates the format
doesn't allow for deep policy discussion
ten candidates on a stage in it to
respond in 30-second rebuttal that
doesn't policy is impossible there okay
it's talking points in zingers when
you're running against Trump who doesn't
even understand policy but is very
effective in a sort of influence
charisma way to people who are at least
somewhat predisposed to like his style
it's also hard to really dig deep on
policy because whoever goes up against
him if they try to focus on policy
Trump's not going to have it he can't
debate policy so I actually don't really
see a path for policy to ultimately be
the focus in this election
unfortunately there's gonna have to be
some other way to defeat Trump mm-hmm do
you think that like progressives have to
play into that you think like Bernie
might have to play into like you know he
started his campaign with a big speech
about like where he came from
like his identity do you think yes to
favor that more whoever wrong whoever
wins the nomination and runs against
Trump is going to have to beat Trump at
his own game in the sense that just
going up there and doing wonky deep
political discussions is just not going
to defeat Trump I wish it were different
but I'm just sort of recognizing the
political reality that we live in I hope
whoever wins is ready for that yeah
thanks all right appreciate the phone
call thank you very much yeah great to
hear from you
one of today's sponsors is impeach the
card slap game
you cannot slap Donald Trump in real
life but you can slap him in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach and use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout all one word
awesome for parties when you're having a
few drinks I've been playing it with
some friends of mine currently has a 5
out of 5 star rating on Amazon and it
combines clever satire about the Trump
administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
really lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and really how much
thought went into the humor and the
political commentary the game covers a
ton of themes global warming Russian
collusion tax cuts for the wealthy
impeach the cards slap game is perfect
if you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members you
might even learn something new about the
Trump administration while you're
playing the game it's a perfect gift for
anyone who has a sense of humor about
Trump or get it for yourself and have a
really fun and witty game to play when
people come over you can even play it
tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word